Forget being a vampire, could techonology
keep us young forever?
Hey everyone Julia here for DNews
In the new movie SELF/LESS, a dying man uses
technology to transfer his consciousness to
a younger man's body.
But what if we could just stay young forever?
Would you want to live forever? if you could
how would you do it?
Some research suggests young blood has rejuvenating
properties, which sounds creepy as all get
out.
I talked about it in a previous episode.
So if you want to learn more about it, you
vampire you, check it out… link in the description
Other research suggests we should tackle the
ways our cells divide.
As our cells divide throughout our lifetime,
the ends of our DNA start to get shorter and
the DNA could fray, causing age related illnesses
like cancer.
But we’ve got telomeres, little caps that
are like the tips of your shoe laces.
By keeping the caps on our DNA long and healthy,
we could extend our lifespan.
Again more on that in a past episode.
But that’s mostly biological.
How could technology help us live longer?
There are lots of companies and investors
jumping on this bandwagon.
Investor Peter Thiel donated a total of $500,000
towards SENS, or Strategies for Engineered
Negligible Senescence.
This type of research is focused on finding
a cure for aging.
Maybe the future would be tailored to us.
Just like a made it your way burger at a fast
food restaurant, maybe you could have your
medicine made just for you.
At that’s what the world Thiel hopes to
see.
He invested in other companies, too.
Like Counsyl, where you could start off with
a genetic analysis to see if you or your kids
might be at risk for any diseases.
If it it turns out you’ve got a rare disease,
there are companies out there that want to
hack into your immune system.
Immunosoft says they can program your cells
to cure disease.
They would take some of your cells, wrap them
with a bit of DNA that would code for a protein
that you’re missing, then insert into your
system.
Then your own body would start to produce
that protein.
Or maybe if nothing’s too wrong with you
but want to keep an eye out just in case,
a watch could help you.
There’s a lot of wearable tech out there
right now to keep track of things like how
far you walk and your heart rate, stuff like
that.
But imagine a device that could alert you
to a health issue, before it happens.
Well that’s on its way to becoming a reality.
Google is investing in a combination of a
smartwatch and nanoparticles.
You’d swallow the nanoparticles in a pill,
and because they’re magnetic they’d be
able to explore your body for any diseases.
Maybe they’d attach on to a cancer cell
or monitor chemicals in your blood.
If anything is out of the ordinary they’d
alert you on your watch!
But not surprisingly Google’s not stopping
there, In September of 2013, Google announced
Calico, a company that focuses on fighting
aging.
While nothing major has come from this company
yet, they are partnering up with major Universities
like Harvard and UC schools.
Their partnership with UCLA focused on technology
that could modulate the body’s stress responses
which is known to trigger inflammation, disease
and aging.
But a lot of this technology is still a long
way off, so it remains to be seen whether
any of it will become reality.
If you want to live long enough to see these
advances, stick to the old school approach.
Don't smoke.
Get plenty of exercise.
Eat right.
And if you’re a budding scientist who wants
to come up with your own anti-aging solutions,
maybe go see Self/Less for inspiration.
The movie comes out July 10th and stars Ben
Kingsley as a wealthy man, dying from cancer,
who undergoes a radical medical procedure
that transfers his consciousness into the
body of a healthy young man, played by Ryan
Reynolds.
Sounds like an interesting future.
If you see it, tell us what you think.
So do you wanna stay young forever?
Let us know in the comments below.
Like, subscribe …